hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben zuschauer herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video auf
meinem kanal ich habe mir hier schon
ebay fehlt angeschaut aber zum fels und
ganz wieder andere sorten von fans
allerdings noch keine tattoo fails denn
das werden wir heute tun never don't
give up but don't give up alter das
heißt ja dann soll aufgeben in der tat
die nächste person wollte sich
deutschland hinten auf die schulter
tätowieren lassen hat das auch getan
allerdings steht dort nicht deutschland
sondern deutschland
das l hat er wahrscheinlich auch
verstehen weil er so ein lusa ist jede
person wollte sich genauso wieder
deutschland typ etwas auf die schultern
tätowieren lassen uns war es also ich
bin großartig dabei rausgekommen ist
allerdings dass hier
es heißt immer noch eine ausnahme aber
dass er vergessen
wahrscheinlich ist dass er auf seiner
stirn weil er so ein esel ist get better
ich frage mich einfach ob die tätowierer
das nicht gemerkt haben dass da auf
seiner vorbereiteten dings
rechtschreibfehler drin ist hat zuviel
handelt es sich nicht um irgendein
rechtschreib oder grammatikfehler
sondern es ist einfach komisch ich weiß
nicht warum man sich ein baby auf den
unterarm tätowiert dass eine socke ist
aber ja wenn man es schön findet kommen
wir nun allerdings wieder einmal zu
einer person die sich etwas auf die
schulter tätowieren lassen und zwar only
got the judge me allerdings wurde mal
wieder ein buchstabe vergessen und ich
weiß nicht wie gut englisch können aber
ihr könnt die buchstaben einfach mal in
die kommentare schreiben
zum nächsten feld brauche ich glaube ich
gar nichts sagen das ist so ironisch das
ja das ist der fels knowledge
ich war seidiger das war's ein
komplettes my life genauso geht der
sorgen hier frage ich mich dann ehrlich
gesagt auch wieder gar nichts mehr aber
gut machen wir direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten tag fällt zwar wollte sich hier
jemand auf den unterarm tätowieren
lassen
es wurde allerdings darauf tätowiert
john wayne ja ich ja das ist ja eine
doppelte bestrafung so du hast
einerseits irgendwas beschissenes auf
deinem körper stehen und du musst es
dann auch noch weg machen und das kostet
auch noch geld oder du lässt es halt
stehen aber wie es dann halt von jedem
haus gelagert und ich mal zum thema aus
lachen das ist ja auch noch so eine
sache
das am unterarm kann man ja noch
irgendwie verdecken durch irgendwie nun
wo die oder keine ahnung was er bei
diesem tattoo fan kann man das
allerdings nicht so richtig verdecken
er wollte sich dies auf die stirn
tätowieren lassen dabei ist aber ging es
mit j rausgekommen
am nächsten tag wollte im typ richtig
randale betreibt wollte sie richtig
gegen das system stellen und hat sich
deswegen auf seinen unterarm
jetzt ist sam tätowieren lassen
ja also hat sich auf jeden fall gegen
das rechtssystem gestellten zur nächsten
tour hat sich jemand das gesicht seiner
mutter und darunter den schriftzug mama
auf den unterarm tätowieren lassen und
das ist eigentlich an sich eine ganze
sache denkt man sich aber ich finde der
tätowierer hat vielleicht ein bisschen
verkackt also ich will der familie echt
nicht zu nahe treten aber sieht die so
aus die mutter
da hätte ich mein geld zurückgefordert
der diktatur feld spielt sich ebenfalls
auf dem unterarm ab und zwar wollte dort
eine person no regrets draufstehen haben
also zu deutsch übersetzt ich bereue
nichts darauf tätowiert wurde allerdings
noch wie gerd eigentlich ist es heute
einfach nur ein rechtschreibfehler jetzt
video und beim nächsten tag vergeht
sogar genau in die gleiche richtung die
person wollte nämlich auf seinem arm
stehen haben retten nothing also bereuen
nichts also der gleiche sind wie vorhin
schon darauf tätowiert wurde allerdings
mit redsnow hin
machst du nicht als vorletzten tattoo
fälle habe ich einen richtig hilfen für
euch und zwar wollte dort ein pärchen so
mega suite sein und jeder wollte sich
auf den unterarm sollen puzzleteil
tätowieren lassen allerdings wir bereits
seht passen die puzzleteile einfach
nicht zusammen kommen wir gehen jetzt
zum letzten tag fällt ja
brauche ich glaube ich gar nichts mehr
zu sagen
an der stelle habe ich das heute wieder
ist allerdings auch beenden wenn die
freunde wenn euch meine reaktion auf
diese dummen lustigen witzigen tattoo
fans gefallen dann will ich mich selber
einen daumen hoch von euch unter dem
video hier freude schreibt mir auch mal
ein in die kommentare
welchen tattoo verlieren bescheuerten
fandet also wo habt ihr euch wirklich
gedacht dicker was ist denn mit dir
falsch gelaufen blog auf eine weitere
folge tattoo fans mit luca habt dann
abonniere außerdem gern meinen canalis
kostenlose verpasst keine videos mehr
und falls sie schon abonnent seinen sieg
gerne auf die glocke denn dann bekommt
er eine benachrichtigung sobald ich ein
neues video hochladen und jetzt kommt
das auto präsentiert von sandra
[Musik]
warum es bratwurst richtig lag habe